-I have a deck of cards here,
very simply,
I just want you to touch
the back of one card,
touch the back of one.
-The back? Okay.
-Can they look?
-Perfect. Take it out.
just take it out.
-Okay.
-I want you to look at it.
I want to show
the entire audience.
You can show Jimmy.
It doesn't matter if I see it.
Actually,
it doesn't even matter.
Scarlet has chosen the five
of hearts, the five of hearts.
Very good choice, Scarlett.
What I'd like you to do is
I'd like you to write your name
really big across the face
of that five of hearts,
really, really big.
-He's gonna put this on eBay.
-As big as you possibly can.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-In case that magic stuff
doesn't work out.
-Perfect. Cap that pen so you
don't get dirty.
I'm going to let this dry off.
I want everyone
to get a good look
at what the five
of hearts looks like
with Scarlett's name on it.
Scarlett,
it would be fair to say
that this card is the only card
in the entire world --
-The card doesn't even say your
name, it Rafi.
-Well, I thought I would just.
-There's no way I
could have known that, correct?
-No.
-Perfect. Scarlett,
I'm going to take
your five of hearts
with "Rafi" on it
and I'm going to fold it
in half. Just like this.
I'm going to fold in half again,
just like that.
And Scarlett, here's where
the weird part comes in.
-What's gonna happen?
-I know I'm freaking out.
That's what I said,
-Me too! I know. I know.
-Scarlett.
-Yes, sir?
-Can you please open your mouth?
-Holy crap.
-Just a little bit. Perfect.
And, Scarlett?
-Uh-huh?
-Can you please bite down
on your card and hold it there?
-[ Muffled ] Okay.
-Perfect. Scarlett,
we're gonna take the next card
in the deck, next card
is the eight of spades.
-Yeah, we're gonna go through
the whole deck.
[ Laughter ]
-You got that Sharpie?
Where'd that Sharpie go?
-Oh, here, here.
-Scarlett, I'm going to take
that Sharpie,
I'm going to do the exact same
thing with the eight of spades
that you did
with that five of hearts.
I'm going to write my signature.
My name really big across
the eight of spades.
The eight of spades
with my name on it.
Give me that cap.
I'm going to cap that pen.
-Alright.
-Fantastic.
I'm going to do the exact same
thing with that eight of spades
that we did
with your five of hearts.
-Licking a lot of saliva.
-Yeah, yeah.
And I'm going to take
the eight of spades,
I'm going to fold it in half and
fold it in half again and again.
The eight of spades.
[ Muffled ] Goes in my mouth.
Jimmy, can you grab
that pen one more time?
-Oh, God.
-Watch closely.
I don't want
to touch your card.
-Oh, here?
Don't.
[ Cheers ]
-What is going on?
This is not a trick.
This is the worst.
You're just trying to
kiss Scarlett.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What the heck is happening?
-Oh, my God! That is crazy.
-Scarlett.
-What?
-Did you feel anything?
-Yes, I did.
[ Laughter ]
-I felt nothing, by the way.
-I kind of felt
something, too, Scarlett.
Scarlett, I'm glad you did,
because, because now
in my mouth, I now have
Scarlet's five of hearts.
-Can I take it out?
-Open it up.
-[ Laughs ] Hey!
-Scarlet now has --
-[ Gasps ]
-My card.
-How is that possible?
-How did that happen?
How did that happen?
-You have made a deal
with the devil.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Scarlett and I are about to
face off in a game called
"Box of lies."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's how it works,
upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects
neither of us have seen before.
Taking turns, Scarlet and I
are going to select a box,
open it on our side of the table
out of view of the other person.
You remove the object from
the box show to the audience,
then look at your opponent
and tell them what's in the box.
You may be lying.
You may be telling the truth.
Your opponent has to guess
either lie or truth.
If you guess correctly,
you got a point.
You guess wrong,
the other person gets the point.
First one or two points wins.
Here we go,
Scarlett, you're our guest,
please pick the first box.
-[ Exhales deeply ]
Which one should I pick?
[ Audience shouts ]
One?
Four, four, okay.
[ Audience shouts ]
-Four.
Four. Alright. It looks like
it's a light box
already hint number one.
-Oh, man.
-Four perfect. That's the one
I saw in rehearsal.
-You're lying.
-But that's not the game.
-No way, dude.
-Oh.
-Ooh it's so heavy.
[ Laughs, groans ]
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs]
-[ Laughs ]
-Ooh boy!
-It is
a hot dog bun
shaped like the Hulk.
-Oh, my gosh. A hot dog bun
shaped like the Hulk?
But wait,
you're laughing.
So that means you're trying
to fake me out
because maybe it really
is a hot dog bun shaped
like the Hulk.
Which would be
very reverse psychology of you,
very actor-y of you,
which you are an actor.
-What --
-Scarlett Johansson.
-What is it?
-Yeah. You know.
It's right in front of you, man.
What do you think?
It's a hot dog bun
in the shape of the Hulk.
How is that even possible?
I would've had to get a Hulk
mold and bake --
ah, this whole thing a --
And I'm not a baker.
So I'm going to -- I'm going to
say it's impossible.
I'm gonna say you lie.
-Damn it!
-Yes!
What was it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey. Whoa.
-It's me and Gumby.
-Yeah.
-Sitting on a park bench,
clearly.
-You're both sitting on a park
bench. It's kind of good.
You should keep that one.
Which numbers? Which number?
[ Audience shouting ]
-[ Imitates straining ]
Gosh, I didn't know
that we had
allowed to have bricks
on our show.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] Okay. Alright.
And, uh, hmm.
-This is so stressful!
-Okay. It's just a fun thing.
A lot of people can use it.
Have a great time with it.
Mannequin head
with, uh, diamond eyes
and a, uh, Speedo cover
over the eyes so you can go
swimming underwater
if you have diamond eyes.
And it's useable,
because it's fun.
You can use --
put it around your office
and it's a good time.
-I can't tell whether you've
taken a lot of pauses
because you're trying
to psych me out,
but I cannot imagine
that anybody would think
to make a mannequin
with diamond eyes
and like a little
Speedo goggle cover thing.
-You don't think sometimes,
you know.
-Wait, did Wiz Khalifa make it?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I'm going to say.
There's no way, right?
-You tell me.
-[ Groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-That is terrifying!
Wait!
-It's not terrifying!
-Like, what if it just
what if there wasn't anybody
there and it just, like came up?
Oh, that's frightening.
Yeah, no, that's frightening.
-Sorry.
-Alright, let's do one more,
because now because
I totally destroyed on this
and I totally won, two zip.
So I basically won the game.
But the bonus, the secret box,
if you choose the right number,
is worth a thousand points.
-So, let's do one more round.
-Okay.
-Scarlett, your pick.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience shouting ]
-Which one?
Okay, three.
-People love this number.
-I'm not even --
-Okay.
-I'm not even looking at
the number or the box
or how you turn it over.
-Here, I have to move this
out of the way.
-[ Laughs ]
-Take it, it's so creepy.
-Oh, please. They took it.
It came from my dressing room.
[ Clears throat ] Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-Hmm.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Whoa. Okay.
Alright.
I'm ready for my,
ready for my hint.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
-Yeah?
-I fell into it's eyes.
-Oh, so it has eyes.
-It is --
-A potato.
-Close. It is a plastic cup.
It's a plastic cup
filled with beans.
Uh, baked beans.
It's a cup of beans.
-Alright.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
[ Laughter ]
Let me just say
this right here.
So this is a plastic cup filled
with beans that I can maybe get
if it's a jelly belly
or some type of thing
that you can glue together
and you stick it in a box
and you can carry it
off the box.
If it's baked beans,
that means that glob
around a little bit like,
you know, fall over the box,
beans everywhere.
Total nightmare for my crew
to clean up afterwards.
I don't see that happening.
But maybe you had a very steady
hand by handling that box.
[ Laughter ]
Plastic cup,
it's full of baked beans.
Hmm.
-It's a Starbucks cup.
[ Laughter ]
-You --
Liar!
-Beans!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-1,000 points!
-Agh! She's the best.
Scarlett Johansson.
The winter with 3,000 points.
-Last time I saw you was
at the Montage Hotel.
-Yeah, the montage.
Montage sounds like the part of
"Pretty Woman"
where Julia Roberts
is trying all the dresses.
And it's a montage.
-Yes, no, it's not like that.
-Gosh, what a great hotel.
-It is a great hotel.
-I was at this hotel.
-Julia Roberts was not there.
-She's not always there,
well she might be staying there.
Who knows?
-You never know.
-I went there and we did a show
from Los Angeles.
And so I'm out there
and I was having breakfast and
and then walks by me is
Scarlett Johansson
and your husband
and your beautiful little baby.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
That is a pretty cute baby.
-Thank you.
-Oh, my gosh.
What a fun baby.
-Yeah, see, I'm partial.
-I want to, yeah. Oh, yeah.
I just wanted to, I just wanted
to -- I wanted to kiss the baby.
But you don't do that
to strangers, baby.
So I just I kept my know,
I kept my distance.
-You could have.
-I could have.
-If you'd asked.
I guess I would have let you.
-Yeah.
But, yeah, that was fun.
And I asked you recommendations
on where to go eat
because you've been
staying there for a little while
and I go,
"Oh, I'm here for a week.
Where, where should I go eat,
around the hotel after to work?"
-And I told you to go
to SUGARFISH.
-SUGARFISH.
-Right.
-I didn't know because
my, my, my room looked out
and there's was a tree
covering the last end of that.
So I thought
it was called "Sugarbush."
And I thought and so I thought.
-Oh, you thought it was
a strip club?
-[ Laughs ]
I think it's like a strip club
or like a nightclub.
-So gross!
-Why would you open that up
across from this
beautiful hotel?
-But the need for a strip club
called Sugarbush.
-I don't know. I don't know.
-Is so gross!
-Might be a great name for one.
I have no idea.
I don't know anything
about strip clubs.
I just I don't know.
I know Sugarbush.
I just stay away from I go,
oh, I don't know why that.
But I go I don't know where --
-It sounds pretty sweet to me.
-But so I went to I
actually went to SUGARFISH.
I took your advice, I went,
and it was unbelievable sushi.
Delicious.
-It was the greatest thing ever.
I went in the afternoon.
I went by myself.
I walked in and went up
and sat in the counter.
And you know who was next to me?
The dog whisperer.
Caesar Millan.
-You know, it's César.
-[ Laughs ]
Isn't it César?
-It is César Millan.
Yeah. I guess if you're.
Yeah, I guess if you're --
-If you're what?
Saying it right.
-Well, look, you're Jeb Bush
and Ted Cruz, okay?
You say César, I say Caesar.
Little, Little Caesar's.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza, piazza. you know?
-No, no. Piazza is a different
word than pizza.
Piazza -- pizza, pi-ate-za.
Yeah, yeah.
Little See-ah-zer's.
I got to call Do-mee-no's.
-Okay, those are just all wrong
pronunciations, though.
Clearly mine right though.
His name is César, isn't it?
-His friends call him Caesar.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever you were drunk
at that point.
-I was I was I did have
a lot of sake with him, yeah.
Well, I figured
I walked over to Sugarbush.
Why not?
Do what got to do there.
Oh, boy.
Come to the stage.
She's no dog.
But we're gonna whisper
all the time.
How exciting, you have your own
movie, "Black Widow."
You have your own Marvel movie.
-Yes, yeah, we just finished it
a couple of weeks ago.
We shot the film in London.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
I'm so excited!
I've been so excited about it.
-I'm so excited about it.
I can't wait to share it
with everybody.
It was -- It was --
It was fantastic.
-It really was.
-I mean, I'm partial,
but I'm pretty excited about it.
Yeah, it was -- it was --
honestly, it brought a closure
to me that I needed.
-Really?
-Yeah.
'Cause I was kind of, you know,
wiped out after that last one.
I mean, emotionally
and literally. Yeah.
-Yeah.
By the way, I didn't know,
and I hadn't
talked to you since then
because we couldn't say
anything.
Marvel didn't allow you
to tell me any news at all.
-Especially that.
-Yeah, that was a big one.
-Everyone knows, right,
what happens?
-Well...
-Well, it doesn't matter.
-If you don't know, we're sorry.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Um, there's very few
certain things,
but, like, definitely death's
pretty certain, right?
-Yeah, yes, of course.
-Yeah, definitely for sure.
But people will not --
they just don't want --
they won't -- they definitely
don't believe it, and --
and have tried to convince me
that my character
did not actually die,
that maybe my character exists
in an alternate universe or --
but, no, I think death
is a pretty final thing.
-Did you, uh -- Did you take
anything from the set?
-Um, did I take anything
from the set?
-This is a question
that I would ask,
'cause I would take something
from the set if I was there.
Like, I would be like, "I'm so
excited to be in a Marvel movie.
I'm never gonna be here again.
-But what are you gonna take?
Like, Captain America's shield?
-Yes, I would take -- yes.
-What? You can't take that.
That's the property of Marvel.
-I'm gonna take Thor's hammer.
-You're gonna get arrested.
What are you gonna do?
Arrest me?
That's better press
for the movie.
[ Laughter ]
Hello.
Marvel should hire me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, congrats on your engagement
to Colin Jost, too.
We love Colin so much.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was on the show --
He was on the show recently
with Michael Che, and, uh --
-Oh, yeah, I saw that.
-You did? Yeah.
And Michael said,
he was like, "I hope --"
He wants to throw
his bachelor party.
-Oh, no.
-He said --
-I don't think
that's a good idea.
You won't let him do --
He says if Colin throws it,
it's gonna be during the day
and boring.
-Yeah, but I feel like if he
throws it,
it's gonna be, like,
by the Port Authority,
and, like,
it's gonna be very local.
I don't think
that's a good idea.
-No...
-None of you know
where the Port Authority is,
'cause you're all
from out of town, right?
Or you do know where it is?
-Port Authority, yeah.
-Yeah, it's --
-It's, yeah.
That's where
it should be, though.
That's where it should be.
-No!
You can't go.
Michael's not throwing it.
-[ Laughs ]
-He's not.
-Alright.
-Is this a thing now?
-No, it's not a thing!
-Michael.
I know where you work, Michael.
-Yeah, Michael,
do not throw this party, yeah.
-Um, no,
I love Michael very much,
and, um, yeah,
he's a delightful guy.
-We'll see what happens.
-"We'll see what happens."
Stay tuned!
-You have two movies I want to
talk to you about.
One is "Marriage Story."
Man, oh, man,
you're getting great buzz
on this and great reviews.
It's you and Adam Driver.
-Yeah.
-And it really isn't so much --
it is a marriage story,
but it's very much
a divorce story, as well.
Uh, and is it Noah...
-Noah Baumbach.
-Noah Baumbach, who I --
Oh, my gosh.
-Yes, yeah, yeah.
-"Squid and the Whale,"
"Greenberg"...
-Yeah, we're really excited
about -- about the film.
It's gotten -- people really
seem to have a kind of, like --
They feel -- people have an
experience when they watch it,
I think because, if you haven't
gone through a divorce --
lucky you --
and either your parents have
or you know somebody --
It's all kind of in there,
and there's just --
The thing about this film,
though, is that it's --
There's a lot of love
in this movie.
It actually has --
what's left, what remains
between the two characters
is a lot of love.
It's very touching,
and, um, it's, yeah.
I'm really proud of it.
We did a lot of hard work on it.
-And on the other side...
-Yeah.
-...is this bizarre and awesome
comedy called "Jojo Rabbit."
-Yes.
-And this is -- if you've --
some people have seen it,
but if you haven't seen it,
can you --
how do we describe it?
-Oh, my gosh.
-A World War II, G-Germany...
-You were supposed to do
the heavy lifting on this one.
[ Laughs ]
-Uh, I don't know
how to make it funny,
uh, but it is
very unbelievably funny.
Who was this director?
-It's Taika Waititi,
who directed "Thor: Ragnarok"
and so many great things,
and he...
Okay, I'll try.
-Yeah.
-Okay, it does take place
in Nazi Germany.
Not exactly a hilarious
time or place, but...
um, it -- it's --
it -- [ Sighs ]
Gosh. Why? Why?
You were supposed to do this!
-Alright you want me to do it?
-Okay, you do it.
It's a little boy named Jojo.
-Right, Jojo.
-He's ten years old.
-Right, who's --
That I play Jojo's mother,
and the film...
He is, um, a character
who has lost his father,
and he is desperately
missing him
and so creates this imaginary,
kind of, father figure,
who's, like, the ten-year-old
imaginary version of Hitler,
and he's in the
Hitler Youth Program,
and so it's this kind --
Stop!
-No, no, it's like --
but it's --
Y-Y-Y-You'll see it --
-I'm trying!
-When you see it,
you'll, you know, it's --
-Just go see it.
-Go see it.
It's really -- really, yeah.
-It's great.
It's so unusual. It's so fun.
It's so powerful.
-You have a great connection
with that kid, though.
He was amazing.
-Roman, ah, he's such a --
He's so funny and great
in the movie.
His delivery
is so charming and natural --
-But you two were so charming
and perfect together.
-He's lovable.
He's a lovable kid.
The movie has so much heart.
It has so much hope.
It's so unique and original,
and audiences love it.
-It's unique,
and you never forget it,
and the audience freaked out.
-Yes.